il est temps qu il devienne roi je
puisse enfin appliquée pour les seules
cordes à mon fils aîné est père je suis
l'aîné ah bon ben oui comme je suis né
deux ans avant mon frère de mon vivant
jamais le trône ne reviendra gilbert
genou se comprend j'aimerais que tu
avais compris la faudrait savoir tu dis
je n'ose comprends c'est une expression
terrible accident car c'est un accident
je pourrais te papa donnez leur de me
faire peur aux femmes était son fils
quand même avez-vous tenté à nouveau de
m'assassiner en empoisonnant par exemple
moi nous tenons encore donc ça c'est
normal alors on se dit bon écoute et si
tu ne renonce pas au troll je ne peux
rien faire pour toi fond c'était une
blague
vous savez moi tout ce que je veux c'est
être un artiste pour pouvoir faire mon
numéro
quand l'avion se pose sur la piste
tu crois en avions une idée je te disais
qu'il était con